i'm john luceike reading for reviewer
andrew king like its acclaimed
predecessor spelunky 2 is a rare
platformer that demands to be played as
much as a tactics game
as it does a mario game as you learn or
relearn how to survive
success requires a willingness to think
three moves ahead
some tiles are booby-trapped to shoot
arrows as you leap through their line of
sight
some vases summon a relentless ghost
when smashed
some pottery hides snakes and tarantulas
you really shouldn't even move from your
initial spawn point without pausing for
a moment to pour over every
treacherous inch of the screen spelunky
2 resembles the opening level of the
first game
at least at first you have a whip you
have some bombs and you have a rope you
can toss into the ceiling to climb
to otherwise inaccessible heights
the creatures you encounter like bats
snakes and spiders will be familiar too
but from there the game quickly
bushwacks its way into unfamiliar
territory
there are robots that turn into bombs
when you stomp a button on their heads
mechanical ladybugs that spray fire from
their outstretched wings
and relentless cavemen with boomerangs
each level which is remixed each time
you play via procedural generation
houses new enemies and new environmental
hazards to learn to navigate
after the first biome you're presented
with a choice jungle or
robot volcano and with either comes a
new host of rules to learn
all of this is rendered in the same
expressive cartoon style as its
predecessor
it's slightly crisper and clearer this
time around but it's a tribute to the
timelessness of spelunky's art style
that splunky 2
isn't more of a noticeable step up the
controls match the arts precision
developer moss mouth has added some
quality of life tweaks
you can now run by default and need to
hold a button to slow down
instead of the other way around but
mostly the team didn't mess with a good
thing
the highest praise i can heap on splunky
2 is that in a game where you need to
land jumps on tiny spits of land
leap above spike pits and skirt pools of
lava i never felt like my death was the
game's fault
some things take getting used to sure
but once you get the hang of things
spelunky 2 offers
near-perfect platforming it doesn't feel
as buoyant as some of its genre
contemporaries instead spelunky 2 feels
grounded
your jump won't take you very high and
your puny whip necessitates getting
close to enemies
the game's many traps unpredictable
procedurally generated world
and punishing fall damage mean that the
longer you spend
airborne the less likely you are to make
it back to the ground in one piece
spelunky 2's ever-present sense of
danger encourages you to make
careful calculated decisions if you take
the time to analyze the screen before
choosing your next move
getting there is usually easy i often
thought deeply about where to go
but that was the hardest part
[Music]
however that doesn't mean you still
won't die a lot
mastering splunky 2 is a little like
penning the great american novel
you may have the vocabulary but that
doesn't mean you can put the words
together well
spelunky 2 offers a brief tutorial to
get you in the swing of jumping climbing
and
bomb throwing these rock solid basics
are your sole lifeline as you begin your
adventure
conversely learning each new enemy and
trap is a
baptism of fire it can feel overwhelming
at first
over time though as you gain your
bearings this feeling almost entirely
dissipates
for each seemingly arbitrary death the
game dulls out there is a lesson about a
set in stone rule waiting to be learned
there are some exceptions but on the
whole spelunky 2 does a
stellar job of displaying all the
information you need to know at all
times
once you know how to read it splunky 2
doesn't mess with the original formula
too much but the changes it does make
keep that formula fresh
new biomes like the world filled with
lava and robots
come with new challenges for experienced
adventurers
as each world begins you will be unsure
which tiles you can stand on
and how new enemies will behave it's
extremely satisfying to master a space
that once killed you
instantly you don't unlock new weapons
or level up
instead as the cliche goes knowledge is
power
mechanically the most significant
addition is the inclusion of
mounts these double jumping creatures
can make it significantly easier to
breeze through levels
they move quickly and some can attack
from a distance
offering a nice change of pace on the
runs where you find one
but they're also easy to accidentally
kill
and in the turkey's case there is
incentive to purposefully kill them for
health
i was always extremely grateful to find
a rock dog
a pink fire-breathing goat creature that
can be spotted and tamed in the wild
or purchased at a store and i was
likewise sad to see them go
when hit by an arrow or burned up in
lava a major positive to their addition
is that they can tank that damage for
you effectively granting you another hit
point
and in some cases a second life
at the moment my online experience has
been consistently hampered by
pretty significant lag it's a shame
because rushing through spelunky 2 with
strangers
is a terrific zany time and a great way
to experience the later levels before
you're skilled enough to reach them on
your own
moss mouth has already pushed out
several updates since launch
so hopefully the lag improves over time
the most damning thing i have to say
about splunky 2
is that it mostly feels like more
spelunky the new mechanics
like mounts and the new stage themes
feel right at home
to me splunky 2 seems familiar obviously
this isn't a bad thing
the first spelunky is a fantastic game
and splunky 2
improves on its formula making the best
version of splunky possible
is a worthy goal but spelunky 2 suffers
a little from the
lack of ambition beyond that despite the
great time i'm having with this game
my excitement is tampered slightly by
the nagging feeling that this is
mostly just a better take on the
original design
rather than an ambitious entirely new
thing at least
that seems to be the case right now the
original splunky's proc gen depths hid
secrets that took time for its avid
community to discover
so it's possible that splunky 2 has
secrets of its own that i have yet to
find
and they could push the game in a
different direction from its predecessor
splunky 2 is a successful evolution of
what made the original spelunky work
the tight controls impressive use of
procedural generation
expressive art style and interesting
stage themes are better than ever here
but the more notable changes in how we
play and talk about this game will
likely happen in the coming months as
players discover the heart of the game
and the deep dark depths we aren't yet
even aware
[Music]
exist
[Music]